some breaking news coming into a sermon  this afternoon from Canada reports that  we're getting is that an active shooter  situation a gunman situation is ongoing  in a federation Canada which is the  capital of New Brunswick reports say  that at least four people dead  the situation is ongoing this from local  police they say police continue to avoid  the area of Brookside Drive between main  and Ring Road an incident has resulted  in at least four people killed more  information will be available when we  can confirm regarding the shooting at  this time we can confirm multiple  fatalities and they go on to say that  the incident is ongoing more information  will be made available so breaking news  coming into a sermon this afternoon from  Federation in Canada which is the  capital of New Brunswick that in at  least four people dead there is an  active incident going on involving a  gunman we'll have more on that as and  when we get is